music's biggest night
I am overwhelmed he's back I feel like
I'm like tripping
[Music]
you don't know who's gonna roll out a
giant bed and twerk on it
coming up
[Music]
there's gonna be something for everybody
in my performance
[Music]
I'm just like extremely thankful and
happy and the nominees to watch the girl
I told you was magic
plus how Olivia Rodrigo is battling
Billy eilish in her big Grammy's debut
so cool to be able to look up to someone
like her
brutal out here
and who convinced 12-time winner Lady
Gaga not to
cry and through that friendship I
realize that anything is possible a
special episode of et's the download
counting down to the most exciting night
music starts right now
[Music]
foreign
's biggest night the Grammys are always
filled with surprising moments even more
shocking snubs and of course stunning
performances so what's in store this
year well for starters we're headed to
Sin City what does that mean to get
eight nominations it's something that
I've dreamed about since I was a little
girl I'm a speechless speechless
the Grammys will be worth the wait a
four month wait to be exact after the
winter covet surge led to the ceremonies
postponement and ultimately a venue
change now it's all happening at the MGM
Grand Garden arena in Las Vegas which is
sure to be a party anything else that
happens is just icing on the cake Olivia
Rodrigo tops this year's list of
performers along with Billy eilish Lil
Nas X BTS and her what do you have for
us at the Grammys what's special I can't
give anything away but I will say it's
going to be electric there's going to be
something for everybody in my
performance any surprises I think the
collaboration that's all I'm gonna say
silk Sonic's gonna open up the show what
kind of vibe are we going to get it's
going to give you a little bit of a
reason to get up and dance at the top of
the show
[Music]
as far as the awards there are a lot
more stars up for them as the recording
Academy expanded the number of nominees
in the big four categories from 8 to 10.
last fire diversity is also a high
priority with the academy Valley to
ensure equity and inclusion at every
level including both on stage and behind
the scene
hosting the Grammys one time is a
lifetime achievement hosting it twice is
an opportunity to mess things up so uh
it's terrifying it's exciting the daily
shows Trevor Noah is marking his second
year in a row as MC we're back with an
audience live it comes with an
electricity and an energy that you get
to feed off of that's what this year's
Grammy is going to feel like what makes
him the perfect host so funny so smart
he is the perfect host for something
like this he's also a real fan in The
Rook it's basically you know the year's
biggest all-round concert you don't know
who's gonna roll out a giant bed and
twerk on it
so as Trevor teases some surprises he
may also be bracing for an awkward run
in with Kanye West who was banned from
performing at the show after using a
racial slur directed at NOAA on social
media however Kanye's not banned from
attending I'm a comedian I was born to
be in trouble so um let's see what
happens
yeah here's hoping Kanye doesn't turn
the Grammys into the Oscars because we
need the knights top nominees to have
their moment please speaking of them
Leading The Way with a whopping 11
nominations is an artist you may know as
Stephen Colbert's band leader John
Batiste but of course he is so much more
than that
[Music]
what does it mean
s most nominations of any artist on this
plan
[Music]
was unexpected I just put my head down
and do the work and create
Donruss from
the soundtrack of Disney's
I just really love music I love what it
can do in the World Justin Bieber
eight nominations each when I think
about these Awards it's always
confirmation and not validation but you
know it's so great to be recognized for
something that you already love
[Music]
fight for you her is up for album and
song of the year but can she handle
another trophy I have a a makeshift
shelf right now but I'm working on like
a really fancy one like where they're
lit up and in the whole things
I feel like I'm an am in a dream I feel
like I'm like tripping seven time winner
Billy eilish could add seven more to her
trophy case this year she's nominated
again in the top three General
categories and going head to head with
Olivia Rodrigo
[Music]
I've like dreamed about the Grammy since
I was a little girl I'm so excited for
the day and I've just been a fan of it
forever and so it's just going to be so
exciting to go there in the flash with
her best new artist nomination Olivia
has a chance to sweep the big four which
also includes album song and record of
the year and if she does the 19 year old
will be the second youngest to do it
behind Billy who did it two years ago
duh listen it's a no-brainer that both
Olivia and Billy are in the same
conversation yeah but not so easily
explained this year's snubs and
surprises and why this Grammy veteran
has just one chance to win
Shake
[Music]
it
Off
Taylor Swift is gonna have to shake off
her one and only nomination she's up for
album of the Year defending her title
with Evermore
[Music]
and swifties I know what you're thinking
the re-release of Taylor's red album
didn't come out until after the
submission deadline but the new girl on
the scene Olivia Rodrigo is giving her
credit where it's due
I'm the biggest Swifty in the whole
world I think she is the most genius
songwriter I'm just obsessed with her so
obsessed that she gave her writing
credits for inspiring not one but two
songs on the sour album but not so fast
the Grammys withdrew t-swift's name
before voting so Olivia and Taylor are
now competitors for the album of the
Year honor
drama drama and a person she knows all
too well Kanye West he's their
competition too we're just hoping
nothing like this happens
no Taylor
I'm really happy for you I'm let you
finish
[Music]
gaze got five knots total most of them
for donda the big surprise here this is
his first album of the Year nomination
as a lead artist in 15 years everybody
want to know what I would do if I didn't
win
I guess we'll never know
we know it's not likely his ex Kim will
be there to cheer him on but one
conflict gay was able to resolve
recently was his Feud with Drake the two
were going Toe to Toe for best rap album
[Music]
let the certified lover boy turn the
tables and snub the recording academy by
withdrawing his two nominations we don't
know why but over the years he's been
critical of the award show if there's
people who have regular jobs who are
coming out in the rain in the snow
spending their hard-earned money to buy
tickets to come to your shows you don't
need this right here I promise you you
already won
but it's a year of
year
it's been 40 years since Swedish pop
group ABBA dropped any new music at all
but with the release of voyage they
ended up earning their first Grammy
nomination ever I still have faith in
you is up for a record of the year I
still have faith in you
but here's a Duo who knows a thing or
two about winning
[Music]
Billy eilish and her brother Phineas can
now both brag about Best New Artist
honors at the Grammys Billy won two
years ago and Phineas despite already
having eight golden gramophones is
nominated in that category now so how
could a guy this decorated qualify
because big bro is striking out on his
own
that's what they'll say about
I think I'm I'm right where I want to be
right now it's just a reminder to to
Really open your eyes and look around
and be there
this is up against nine other artists
none of which exploded on the scene
quite like Olivia Rodrigo
for a whirlwind year also included a
triple platinum album an SNL performance
baby a trip to the White House
I'm so great
and some new ink with bestie Iris Apatow
I think your gloves might be covering it
but you just got a tattoo
don't tell my parents I was like if it's
on the tip of my finger it's gonna rub
off in here so it's fine Olivia's
Blockbuster debut sour is said to be
inspired by her real-life split from
High School Musical co-star Josh Bassett
it was a break it wasn't a breakup I'm
sorry Ricky but it's a breakup now you
talk about how sour was all about the
the Heartbreak that kept on giving but
what were some of the other things you
did to push through that heartbreak um I
think prioritizing your friends and
especially like female friendships for
me was super helpful and I think more
fulfilling than any like kind of like
boyfriend relationship in my life
Olivia's biggest challenge for best new
artists may come from hip-hop artists
sweetie hello
[Music]
fun fact hip-hop is in her blood her
uncle is M.C hammer and she's got a
famous cousin too actress Gabrielle
Union Plus collabs with some of the
biggest names in the game including Gwen
Stefani her and Doja cat and every time
everybody through my name I'm like oh my
gosh very exclusive very expensive you
know all the icy girl stuff and if
you're looking for the secret to scoring
a Grammy Nom collabs could be the key
Jimmy Allen became the first ever Black
Country Best New Artist nominee after
teaming up with Brad Paisley
my way baby Keem teamed up with his
cousin Kendrick Lamar and the kid Leroy
scored a hit with Justin Bieber
[Music]
will you guys be making more music
together that song was beyond a hit yeah
hopefully I don't know whatever whatever
feels right
[Music]
I mean who could forget how that hit
blew up as soon as it came out last
spring and this year butter is giving
BTS a chance to win their very first
Grammy for Best pop group performance I
know you're so stoked yes but they are
up against some friends from the UK
[Music]
Coldplay is back in the Grammy's race
the group who announced they'll retire
from making new music after 2025 will
compete for best pop Duo group
performance
[Music]
their competition includes my universe
collaborators BTS and Lady Gaga and Tony
Bennett I get no kick from
Champagne the Duo's final album together
love for sale is up for a total six
nominations including traditional pop
vocal album and album of the Year their
competition in both those categories
Justin Bieber
[Music]
his album Justice spawned hit I'm so low
only after hit holy holy holy holy holy
earning him three nominations in the pop
categories another three in the general
categories and a long-awaited r b
nomination Bieber called out the Grammys
last year when he was overlooked in the
r b space now peaches is up for best r b
performance and best music videos
what does it take
to get your first grant it was a tick I
think just takes making good music
country icon Dolly Parton is a pop
princess this year thanks to her
Christmas album
[Music]
[Applause]
for best pop vocal album we had a holly
Dolly Christmas CD that I hope is going
to be around for a long time her friend
and six-time Grammy winner Brandi
Carlile is nominated for the first time
as a pop artist in the best pop solo
performance category something the
Americana singer had some conflicted
feelings about having stayed true to her
folk Roots through her decades-long
career I had no no excuse but to Just
Surrender I'm ready to just sing my
truth and be in the same room with the
best that music has to offer but it was
right
on
time
listen whatever category Brandy deserves
all the awards amen and get how cool
this is at the Grammys she'll be
reuniting with one of her High women
bandmates who's still one of the queens
of modern country
[Music]
Morris's
protest song better than we found it has
earned her a Grammy nod for best country
song IT addresses immigration police
brutality and the black lives matter
movement
oh will we leave this world better than
we found it
the 31 year old is also nominated with
her husband Ryan Hurd for their duet
Chasing After You
[Music]
the recognition from the recording
Academy is a first for Ryan
[Music]
it's just really an amazing little ride
can't explain what a hit song is but you
know it when you hear it and um
just cool I finally have one Mickey
Guyton is Riding High after the biggest
year of her career which included a
performance at the Super Bowl I am
freaking out oh my God the 38 year old
is up for best country solo performance
and best country song for remember her
name
and she's the only black woman ever to
be nominated in the big category best
country album Sturgill Simpson and Chris
Stapleton will compete against Mickey as
will Miranda Lambert John Randall and
Jack Ingram plus Brothers Osborne who
are set for a performance too Fresh Off
Their ACM win it's amazing to be leaving
here tonight with an award and we can
focus on the Grammys and and hopefully
pull up a performance just as memorable
noticeably missing Morgan Wallen he was
shut out of the Grammys altogether
following his racial slur Scandal
despite having the best selling album of
2021. yeah we fancy like Applebee's on a
date night
get some whipped cream on the top two
and it's nothing but love for first-time
nominee Walker Hayes who is up for best
country song for his viral Tick Tock hit
fancy like have you started processing
that you're also a Grammy nominee as
well we didn't any of this what happened
when we wrote this song so we're just
enjoying it fancy life
and now that song will be stuck in my
head all night long do you know the tick
tock dance no I don't know the tick tock
dance but coming up look back at Lady
Gaga's Grammy's debut I really wanted to
win tonight only for my fans
et's the download returns right after
the break
[Music]
if you wanna buy her where's
yes
Lady Gaga and Tony Bennett they have
some history they sure do and before
their Hit album Love for Sale earned its
five nominations they connected to make
their first eight years ago and E.T was
there when they were first nominated
together in 2015 that's when they
revealed how they became a match made in
music heaven
[Music]
Tony heard me sing some standards for
the first time and I was like oh gosh
the legendary Mr Tony Bennett but here
we are today and we're very happy to be
celebrating our Grammy win tonight
[Music]
ET was with Gaga and Tony in 2015 right
after cheek to cheek won best
traditional pop vocal album and right
before they performed together on the
Grammy stage
[Music]
like about her is there's the unexpected
and that makes it very interesting it
makes it makes for a very good
performance all the time and I
understand that he actually stopped you
from actually quitting music all
together is that true he did you know I
was going through a hard time as
everybody does but when I met Tony I
found a friend
[Music]
and five years earlier in 2010 E.T met
Gaga backstage when her debut album The
Fame earned her her first two trophies
two Grammys tonight what do you take
those Grammys do you dress them up do
you put some sequins on them Grammy's
stay nice and easy
but I really wanted to win tonight only
for my fans
okay the Grammys are special it's like
the Super Bowl of of music you feel it
you second you hit that carpet Kanye
West is a winner 22 times over but E.T
first met him in 2005. right after he
learned that at his first show he was
nominated across 10 categories including
album of the year for College Dropout
I'm so self-conscious that's why you
always see me with at least one of my
watches like I would never I never would
doubt that I would get nominated
so I'm talking about baby I'm the one
rapping with the Rockefeller charm plus
they got the pretty girl right next to
my almond yes Kanye is the bomb and Wes
the name and that's right at the Grammys
hey Ten Years Later E.T caught him on
the red carpet during happier times with
Kim K I'm just extremely happy can you
tell by my face
I'm appreciative of my nomination but I
just really wanted to use the stage to
perform this song only one that was it's
extremely important to me
my only one
is like the morning sun you keep on
Rising till the sky knows your name this
is my first Grammys I've ever been to
and I'm already so overwhelmed there are
so many famous people here how do you
handle it Kanye's on again off again
enemy Taylor Swift first arrived at the
Grammys in 2008 the then 18 year old was
totally Starstruck while celebrating her
Best New Artist nomination so I'm just
gonna walk in there and be laid back
about it and just have a great time no
matter what happens I'm wearing jewelry
that is like so much more expensive than
my house I think then in 2012 she teased
to ET the release of red I'm already
thinking about the next record I've been
writing it for the past year so I like
to write a record for a good solid two
years and then didn't pick the best song
[Music]
never ever ever
record she'd reclaim remaster and
re-release almost a decade later well
what was it like going back revisiting
that era and doing it all over again it
was an amazing experience it was a short
film
one of my favorite songs I've ever
written
symbolism it's just a lot of a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Taylor's country sister Carrie Underwood
is coming in hot this year with two
nominations in two different genres best
country duo or group performance with
Jason Aldean this song has been uh you
know a big song obviously for us all
year and it's nice when you have a plan
and it works out and best Roots gospel
album for my savior
[Music]
15 years ago the American Idol was in
disbelief as a first-time winner taking
home two Awards including best new
artists I think it's sinking in a little
more they keep handing me these things
to hold for pictures I realized how
lucky I am I honestly do and how blessed
I am
can't wait to see what Carrie is going
to wear to the Grammys as well that all
right that does it for us today make
sure to join us Monday for a full recap
of music's biggest night and moments you
didn't see on TV goodbye everybody
come on oh you're taking me down
[Music]